way back when I was six years old
reading comic books and I love comic
books in the centerfold of a Superman
comic book was a description not a comic
but text of how to build something
called a crystal radio and what
fascinated me was that you could build
it out of pot you could find in your
house or on the street at no cost I mean
I needed an empty toilet paper roll some
wire my father's old razor blade a
pencil lead that was pretty much free I
needed an earphone which I stole from
the candy stores telephone booth and I
needed something called a variable
capacitor I had no idea what that was
but I know i could buy it down a canal
street so my mother took me down in the
subway i walked with the first
electronic shop banging my fist on the
table and said I need a variable
capacitor and the guy said what size and
it blew my cover so I explained what i
wanted the voice is I know just what you
need so we sold us for a few pennies
this variable capacitor I brought it
home wyd it up and I heard music coming
out of the earphone no battery no power
basically free now this was clearly
magic I decided I better figure out how
this works and that's what launched me
on this career if you will of
engineering and I'm still trying to
figure out how it works
went to graduate school that are mighty
and there I started working for the
legendary Claude Shannon the man who
invented and created information theory
brilliant guy and he was he was then and
still is my role model and I notice that
all my classmates were doing their PhD
research on the area that he had created
information theory and in my mind this
was a very crowded area Shannon had done
most of the easy good work solid work
who always left was hard and probably
inconsequential so I imagined but I was
surrounded by computers both at MIT and
at MIT Lincoln Laboratory where I spent
my summers working and I said one day
these computers are going to have to
talk to each other and there was no
adequate way by which they could do so
so this really challenged me this is a
good problem it'll probably be important
there's a lot of low-hanging fruit let's
go for it so I started working in the
area which eventually became the
internet and what I did for my
dissertation was to basically create the
mathematical theory of data networks
suggested and introduced the idea of
taking messages and breaking them up
into fixed length blocks we now call
those things packets and develop the
underlying technology of packet
switching which now drives the internet
backbone
so September second 1969 the first
packets which we now call those things
routers arrived in my laboratory to UCLA
it was based on a design that we had
specified the manufacturer create it
arrived there under the Labor Day
weekend on the Monday following on the
Tuesday following the labor day we
hooked that switch up to our host
computer with UCLA the host computer was
basically a time shared computer serving
the computer science department at UCLA
so we had a switch and we had a computer
it wasn't going anywhere but I like to
say that that's the day that the infant
internet took its first breath of life
this switch which was ported the
internet looked out in the world was
born and so a computer a month later the
second node received their switch up at
Stanford Research Institute otherwise
known as sr I 40 miles to the north of
us UCLA they're up in the Bay Area we
put a high-speed line between our switch
and their switch they connected their
computer we had our computer and what we
wanted to do was now talk from our
computer through this very small to node
network to their computer this was
October 29th 1969 so what was the
message we want to send all we want to
do is log in from our computer to their
computer now to log in you have to type
l 0 g and that remote machine is smart
enough to know what you're trying to do
it types the inv you ready to go Charlie
climb my program and myself build to Val
up at the other end and we had a
telephone connection so we could
communicate and make sure we watched
what happened so we type the L and say
you get the L just got the L tap do you
get the L got the oh that the G got the
Jeep crash the sry computer crashed so
the first message ever on the internet
was low as in lo and behold
we couldn't have anticipated a shorter
more prophetic more succinct message
than low
two months before the September date on
July third of 1969 a press release was
put out of UCLA and in there I'm quoted
in writing I've got a copy of the press
release well I do articulate the vision
I had and basically what I said was that
the internet would be always available
always on everywhere that anybody with
any device could get on at any time and
it would be invisible just like
electricity is invisible what I did not
anticipate was that my 99 year old
mother would be on the internet and she
was until she passed away two years ago
I didn't see the social side our vision
then was computers talking to each other
and people talking to computers but not
people to people and of course that's
what's driving the internet these days
the communities that form the Facebook's
all the social networking all the email
is about people communicating with each
other miss that side of it
you